this is jack dorsey the deca billionaire
founder of twitter
and square in november of 2017 and this
is jack dorsey in march of 2021 within
this three and a half year time span
it seems like jack has aged 10 to 15
years
aside from a major jump in physical
aging it seems like jack has also made a
significant mental transformation
as well he's more mellow reserved and
distant than
ever before so what happened to jack
well to really understand this
transition i think we have to look at
the entirety of his career
and analyze all of the shifts throughout
it taking a look back at jack's first
business endeavor
we go all the way back to 1990 when he
was only 14 years old
at the time jack started working on some
open source software
that could help some local taxi
companies dispatch their drivers
a couple of years later jack would
enroll in the university of missouri
where he of course majored in computer
science he would only complete a little
over two years at the university of
missouri
before transferring to new york
university ironically
he would drop out of nyu but not before
completing two full years here as well
he only had one semester left when he
dropped out
after college jack would move to san
francisco in 1999
and work on improving his taxi
dispatching service he would expand the
service to work through the internet
and allow for the dispatching of
couriers and emergency vehicles
as well around this same time jack would
develop a beta program
that allowed blackbeard users to update
their friends and family about their
status
jack says that no one really cared about
the idea at the time
so he stashed it away and continued
working at his dispatch company
things at the dispatch company however
weren't doing so hot
in 2002 we were at the bottom of the
dotcom crash
and jack would get into a fight with the
board members and get fired
this was a massive blow for jack the
dispatching service had been a focal
point in his life since he was 14 years
old
and now he was back to ground zero
feeling defeated
jack would move back home to st louis
and the next couple of years of his life
are actually quite similar to his
current life
jack went ahead and got a nose ring an
s-shaped tattoo
and he would become a licensed massage
therapist really quite a term from his
life in silicon valley
but he didn't leave everything behind it
seems like he was reluctant to leave
behind programming
as jack would attempt to create a chair
massage service for programmers with
risk takes
as you would guess this effort did not
go very far
and jack would move back to san
francisco in 2005 and get a programming
job at odeo
odeo was a podcasting platform that
aimed to take advantage of the rise of
mp3 files
but in 2005 apple announced that itunes
would launch its own podcasting platform
and given the dominance of the ipod odeo
felt that they had no chance against
apple
in reality i don't think they were
actually screwed by any means
in retrospect they were super early to
the market and they probably could have
survived against apple
i mean just take a look at spotify which
was literally founded
after these guys gave up on odeo
nonetheless the audeo team no longer
felt confident in their business
so they started looking for ways to
pivot the company and this is when jack
would bring up his stash idea for a
messaging platform centered on person
status
noah glass really liked the idea and he
was basically all in
evan williams and bis stone twitter's
other co-founders weren't nearly as
enthusiastic
but they went along with the idea on
march 21
2006 jack would make the first tweet
stating
just setting up my twitter later that
year the team would propose a new
direction of odeo to their investors
but their investors weren't impressed
whatsoever
since this wasn't the original project
that the investors committed to
and the fact that they weren't too
interested in a new idea
evan williams would buy back the shares
from the investors and let jack run the
company
as ceo something important to note is
that jack would
actually take out his nose ring and he
would cover up his tattoo to better fit
the ceo look
unfortunately though jack's time as ceo
wouldn't last too long
in 2008 evan williams and the board
would oust jack dorsey
pinpointing a couple of key reasons for
why he wasn't fit as ceo
number one jack hadn't solved the
constant outages that twitter
experienced
number two jack had yet to create a
backup system for twitter
and number three believe it or not was
that jack left work early to go to yoga
classes and
fashion shows evan williams told him you
can either be a dressmaker
or the ceo of twitter but you can't be
both
as you can see it jack has always been a
quirky guy with various interests
outside of work
this isn't a bad thing by any means but
it is uncharacteristic of most tech
company founders
who just worked 24 7 especially in the
early days of their companies
unfortunately for jack this got a mouse
did from twitter
and he was back to ground one once again
they did let him keep his take on
twitter though
so that's good determined to prove
himself though
jack would start looking for new
business opportunities he actually
almost joined facebook but he would
later decide against that
in 2009 one of jack's friends jim
mckelvey was looking to sell a glass
faucet for two thousand dollars
but his inability to accept credit cards
made the entire process
much more difficult so jack and jim
would start a company that would allow
small merchants and sellers to accept
credit cards
and this was of course square but what
was super interesting though was how
jack decided to carry himself during the
early days of square
his yoga and fashion habits didn't serve
him well at twitter
so he decided to emulate one of the most
notable ceos of all time
steve jobs this was a really weird part
of his life
as something just seemed off i mean just
look at these pictures
i'm not sure if he was trying to make a
statement or if he felt forced to fit
into a specific mold
but he was clearly not being himself
during this time period
on the bright side things would start to
finally pick up with his career
not only was square growing rapidly but
in 2011
evan williams would be ousted by twitter
which created an opportunity for jack to
rejoin twitter as executive chairman
in november of 2013 twitter would go
public which made jack a billionaire
worth 1.05 billion dollars
and soon enough jack dorsey would be
reinstated as twitter ceo
in october of 2015. since then his net
worth has continued to grow rapidly
but though he's mostly known for twitter
the vast majority of jack's 12.5 billion
fortune today actually comes from square
so
in retrospect it looks like being fired
from twitter was actually a positive
thing
long term but anyway that brings us to
where we are today
looking back at the story it's pretty
clear that jack never really fit the
mold of a typical ceo
i mean the guy is a massage therapist an
avid fashion fan
and he has plenty of other uncommon
characteristics some of which are great
while others are questionable for
instance
jack walks 5 miles to work every day
this is an
awesome habit and as jack describes it
it's the best investment
he can make meanwhile jack is also known
for only eating one meal per day
or seven meals per week this is
ironically
actually more than he used to eat as he
used to fast on the weekend
meaning that he only ate five meals per
week i think we'd agree that this habit
is quite questionable but nonetheless it
simply further supports jack's bizarre
character traits
it seems like jack was never able to
freely express this side of him
when he became twitter's ceo he dropped
a nose ring
and when he founded square he started
acting like steve jobs
even after he dropped this deep jobs act
he maintained looking like a typical
tech ceo
but this was never really his true self
he had to more or less keep up this
persona
as drifting away clearly had
repercussions such as being fired from
twitter
but jack is no longer the rookie on the
street trying to prove his startup to
investors
he is one of the most established tech
billionaires around and
he no longer needs to act a certain way
to earn the trust of investors
he's able to be himself and this
includes growing out his beard
wearing a nose ring and going bald so
that explains the recent shift in
appearance
but what about the rapid aging well the
reasoning behind this
is twofold starting with the obvious
reason
jack dorsey has been experiencing
unfathomable levels of stress and
pressure
over the past couple of years when
twitter was created
barack obama was one of the first people
to use a platform to promote his own
campaign
but despite that twitter wasn't that
political in the early days
for the most part it was just youtubers
and celebrities posting updates about
their personal lives and promoting their
businesses
since 2016 though twitter has become one
of the most politically divisive
platforms
out there jack dorsey has faced an
onslaught of censorship lawsuits and
public criticism
the right things that twitter should not
be allowed to censor while much of the
left thinks that twitter does not do
their job to prevent the spread
of misinformation regardless of what the
truth is
neither side thinks that jack is doing
his job right and this has garnered him
significant hate from both sides
in fact i'd argue that jack dorsey is
one of the most despised ceos out there
probably only beaten out by mark
zuckerberg and
there's no doubt that such extreme
levels of controversy comes along with
extraordinary amounts of stress and
subsequently rapid aging
given that jack dorsey no longer cares
about looking good for the public
it's not surprising that he doesn't dye
his beard or put on makeup or things
along those lines
but i think the deeper reason for jack's
recent transition
is an internal guilt in may of 2021 jack
said quote
if someone is in pain i am in pain and
over the past couple of years jack
basically witnessed firsthand the
collapse of california
around him the homeless population in
california has skyrocketed
and the pandemic has only made things
worse now
i'm not saying that jack dorsey is some
selfless hero or anything
but something to keep in mind is that
jack literally has nothing else to focus
on
he's not married he's never been married
and he has no kids
so for jack it's basically just work and
his hobbies
he has no one to save his wealth for and
no one to really share it with
and i think he truly feels guilty for
just having all of this money while his
entire city and community
is suffering jack dorsey said that he
wants to give out all of his money in
his lifetime
and he hasn't been afraid to start big
last year he donated a whopping of 1
billion
to charity which was at the time 28
percent of his entire net worth
percentage-wise this is one of the
biggest donations we've ever seen
especially in one go at the end of the
day
jack dorsey has always been a quirky guy
however
he was forced to conform to the ideals
of silicon valley in order to make his
ambitions a reality
now that he's well established though
jack has chosen to unapologetically be
himself
and give back as he wants to quote see
the impact selfishly
in my lifetime do you guys think that
jack dorsey is one of the most
misunderstood souls in silicon valley
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're glad to see his generous
giving
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm ari and i'll see you guys on the
next one